this is Dominic Dominic works at a
5-star restaurant called the pixel
palace they're some of videogames most
popular characters come in to have a
drink sometimes they share stories and
even secrets for as we all know what the
bartender hears is confidential isn't it
so incentive tending bar what in walks
someone that you don't usually forget
Branca
now Blanca is a green fella so naturally
our survey he wanted a margarita but
today he was having the strongest stuff
scotch whiskey said well Blanca's is a
fool stronger than what you're used to
isn't it they said not know computed
well said Willie that's interesting
those are the people to come in here in
good moods I mean usually they come in
they just want to tell me how happy
everything is as a lie I actually hate
people and what was he dead sometimes
but I digress
I always ask me Branca what was the
problem and they said he wanted to give
up the fighting business he didn't want
do it anymore and I'll sit but Blanco
you your natural-born fighter you're big
you're huge
you're green
I don't know what that accounts for
anything but I'm sure it has to somehow
and they says well when you brought this
way for a while yet tend not to want to
be noticed a more your honor me you just
want to sort of blend in with the crowd
okay but what are you thinking about
doing he says oh oh it tried so many
things so many various jobs not so
really like what I said well first I
tried looking after kids at a daycare
center but unfortunately that didn't
work out very well I said our little too
afraid of your appearance he said that
an eating them doesn't help either
apparently child services really frowns
at that no said okay fair enough well
what else did you try I said well I'll
then try being a stunt man for the
Incredible Hulk but it turns out Lou
Ferrigno is so desperate for cash that
he'll do it for much less than I could
ever ask well then try to be a
spokesperson as the Jolly Green Giant
but that didn't seem to work seeing how
most of the test audiences pissed
themselves they had nightmares for a
month
also they kept track of that he said it
was hot not too well said okay well
would you try after that and he said
well I thought I've really found my
calling why became a lifeguard that's in
life God well that's interesting looking
after people saving lives everyday that
must be a lot of fun I said yeah that is
until the electricity goes off
apparently electricity water and people
in water don't really mix that well and
now they said you know I've always
wanted to try a little bit of acting
nothing too heavy but there's something
that requires no violence in it at all
like I said I don't want to fight
anymore
and I said oh would you try then said I
draw a professional wrestling it was not
as you can look and talk as over-the-top
as you want and nobody ever touched you
really well so well that's not it's a
con that didn't work out
as well I'll go - bit of a temper well I
was online the other day and I saw the
spooky one just reviewed me as a
wrestler and I just couldn't take it so
I broke into his house at 8:00 his head
nothing
Wow it's uh but a behind fatality week
for you is attorney says yeah more than
usual
look at me my mom ties get me off but
that's not very interesting story then
something did come around they said he
said he was just walking around and
someone from the electric company came
and saw him they pointed at me and said
hey with all that electricity that you
can just generate naturally there's only
one obvious thing that we can do with
you so they made me a secretary and also
human personal assistants is now now the
secretary I made it's it's non offensive
term or anything
right that they do make me well it's
good that's quite humiliating well so
okay so you found a job you love is
absolutely a darkness why in a bad mood
did you hit anything I've said I've
killed several people
I'm gonna get the death penalty a subtle
in the ground I realized there's hands
where it coughs and that there were two
officers next to him and that the Scotch
whisky was the very last thing you was
ever gonna drink before they executed
him oh sorry to hear that
anything I can do for you this is no no
it's cool it's the electric chair the
officers then took him away in another
song again no I could be wrong but not
one hour later when he was supposed to
be executed the lights started
flickering half of the city went into a
blackout in us wired in mapping it's
just my imagination see I want strange
things as a bartender see almost strange
things at the pizza palace so I'll see a
lot of strange things as a bartender and
the mix of panis
you